is there anything that you could say or
do at this point that would make you
want him back no I'll just know season
17 of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
picked up right where they left off
following Chloe and Tristan Thompson's
split I personally don't watch it back
because I just fired you know what
happens it's just I think a little too
toxic for me to keep reliving stuff like
that Coco admits she and Tristan are
going to therapy to help them co-parent
true so what's the goal just to be able
to like co-parent talk Tristan and I did
a therapy session
I wish I didn't cuz [ __ ] was a really
really hard time for me we saw Chloe
struggling with seeing Tristan face to
face in such a public setting at their
daughter truths first birthday back in
April I'm really so just sick and tired
of being the bigger person
I just sincerely don't want him at shoes
party and that's not wrong of me I want
to uninvite him but she didn't uninvite
him Coco actually had the twenty
eight-year-old NBA star over the day
before trues birthday bash to nip the
awkwardness in the bud though it only
made things more awkward one a
one-handed
[Music]
when et spoke with Khloe and Scott
Disick
back in June they opened up about
showing those difficult moments on the
show the only thing that really matters
is Khloe and our baby true and that's it
nothing else and all support should be
going for her and how she feels thank
you I think this is a part of life I'm
not saying it was unfortunate yeah I
really think I'm in a good place but I
think working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever mission and I always want to
evolve and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people
[Music]